this morning there's new talk over what
President Trump knew when he fired
national security advisor Michael Flynn
sources tell CBS News the president was
told in January about inconsistencies
and Flynn's answers about his contacts
with Russia's US ambassador but the
sources say mr. Trump was not told that
Flynn had lied to the FBI because
lawyers were not sure of that Michael
Flynn pleaded guilty on Friday to one
charge of lying one day later the
president tweeted that he fired Flynn
because he lied to the vice president
and the FBI now Trump attorney John Dowd
helped write the tweet but sources say
it was worded poorly it has now led to
questions about whether the president's
obstructed justice when he told then FBI
director James Comey he hoped Comey
would let the Flynn investigation go now
in a statement Dowd told CBS News the
president's quote the chief law
enforcement officer of the United States
and commis superior he cannot obstruct
himself CBS News legal analyst Ricky
Clement joins us at the table to discuss
so many questions are being raised here
you know when you're a kid in school
you're always told that no one is above
the law so is the president's lawyer
correct that the president cannot be
charged with obstruction of justice no I
don't believe he is correct at all and
we have to look at what the word is used
the word charge scale he may be correct
about that but can a president obstruct
justice of course a president can
obstruct justice and if he does or she
does they must pay the consequences we
have to look at what obstruction of
justice is it's the intent to corruptly
influence impede or obstruct a
proceeding or the fair administration of
justice it's a very unsettled question
and in this regard the lawyer is right
that a part we believe or legal
authorities believe that you cannot be
prosecuted you can't be charged in a
criminal court why do we believe it
because it's never been done which
doesn't mean it can't be done we just so
think it can be well in fact Ken Starr
who investigated President Clinton
during the Monica Lewinsky scandal
actually had his legal scar scholars put
something that said it is legal for a
federal grand jury to indict the
president Leon Jaworski the water
special councils same thing with Nixon
they also concluded that you could
indict a sitting president there's it's
a there is a mixed bag I think that the
great constitutional scholars of the
land right now believe you cannot indict
but be that as it may we certainly know
the remedy is impeachment that is the
traditional remedy and the idea that you
say you can't my client the president
can't obstruct justice
we know from Nixon and from Clinton that
in the articles of impeachment the
charge or one of the charges was
obstruction of justice Jeff Sessions the
president Attorney General said that
Bill Clinton he believed had obstructed
justice and isn't it further complicated
that the the president's saying I didn't
do it my lawyer did it Oh doesn't that
raise questions because when you think
the president's tweeting you think it is
a President himself tweeting of course
that's what we've always been led to
believe well and I think that we still
basically believe that the difficulty of
the lawyer getting involved is twofold
number one let's look at strategy here
the strategy throughout has been this
never happened there was no rush in
collusion the president never obstructed
justice well now we move to another
strategy which is the well if it
happened the President cannot obstruct
justice that's a major shift of the
defense strategy so let's look at the
fact that the lawyer now says that he in
fact wrote or dictated the tweets well
by now talking about that process has he
waived the attorney-client privilege is
there an issue here that he's simply
speaking that out loud creates a whole
new problem that will wind up with
robert muller and when it comes to this
president
it's the tweets in particular that
seemed to get him in trouble he's
written thousands of tweets can they be
used as evidence as of obstruction Sean
Spicer
this past summer said the tweets are his
official statements well I think that
the tweets can certainly be used as part
of the evidentiary arc if there is at
some point in time ever a charge of
obstruction that is for impeachment
purposes you put all the things in the
basket that happened
you put the conversation with Comey you
add
the tweets it doesn't mean and I agree
with the people who have said the
project that there would not be for the
President of the United States a look at
a charge if you will or an impeachment
of the president based on his tweets
alone that's not gonna happen right and
this may never all happen but that
basket is getting more and more full and
robert muller now has all kinds of other
things that he can ask murky Kleman
thank you so much